[Music]
look I hate to sound like a quick crazy
Jezebel article but this is just
seasonal sexual assault it shouldn't be
able to plant one on an unsuspecting
friend wearing a particularly creepy
sweater because the holidays a piece of
plant doesn't make someone your ho ho ho
a Charlie Brown Christmas is horribly
depressing bad animation obnoxious real
kid vs. and a contemporary jazz
contracts that goes well with a nice mix
of eggnog and drano it is best watch
when you're alone and you know things
won't get better anytime soon and at the
end the kid who clings to his blanket
starts the app at about Jesus it's a
Christmas special I don't want to hear
that Jesus the greatest Christmas
special is Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer drunk ass bro lies mystic voice
a dentist's elf that looks like Ellen
DeGeneres and Yukon Cornelius a brawny
explore that also looked like every
Brooklyn drummer or just me without
glasses after crossing
[Music]
mariah carey has three things going for
her that make her better than Whitney
Houston one that cool Whitley think she
does with her voice to the ability to
survival class and three the fact that
she's the only person to make a new
Christmas song legends instant classic
and all i want for christmas is you
michael buble adam levine josh groban
and every other singer you don't get but
your mom wants to have attempted
new Christmas classics and failed many
people can try out yet no one's done it
from Mariah and no i'm not sure if i
should be more ashamed of that rhyme or
the bathtub Joe
[Music]